What is the "Conjunction of the Spheres" in
the world of "The Witcher"?
Simply put, it's what it's like when worlds
collide.
Geralt of Rivia goes up against a number of
bloodthirsty monsters throughout the dangerous
world of Netflix's "The Witcher," and these
encounters give many episodes a horrific flair.
As if that wasn't enough, there's the fact
that whenever Ciri screams, she unleashes
other terrifying monsters from inside the
black monoliths scattered around the Continent.
That's all without mentioning the political
intrigue, the Northern Kingdoms' war with
Nilfgaard, and Geralt's complicated romance
with Yennefer of Vengerberg.
Season 2 deepens the lore behind the Continent,
as Yennefer, Fringilla, and Francesca are
all wrapped up in a dark conspiracy to resurrect
a malevolent demon called Voleth Meir.
The show also briefly touches on why the Continent
is crammed with humans, elves, dwarves, and monsters.
For this history, it calls back to an event
long ago in the timeline called the Conjunction
of the Spheres.
In "The Witcher" books by Andrzej Sapkowski,
the Conjunction of the Spheres takes place
more than a thousand years before Geralt's
adventures with Vesemir, Yennefer, and Ciri.
In fact, it's the reason why the Continent
is such a dangerous place to live, as the
"The Witcher 3: Wild Hunt" explains.
"In a time past, our world intertwined with
another through an upheaval scholars call
the Conjunction of the Spheres."
The cataclysmic event caused different universes
to crash into one another.
And it brought a countless number of other
beings into the world, like all the monsters
that Geralt and his friends go up against
in "The Witcher."
It also brought separate races of human beings
into the Continent, with different languages
and customs.
"Its survivors, lost and forsaken in a new
world."
"New to you."
Monsters and humans weren't the only things
to come through the Conjunction of the Spheres, though.
The disaster also brought magic and chaos
into the Continent.
Eventually, humans realized they could tap
into the mysterious force to cast spells,
which is how the Brotherhood of Sorcerers
got started.
Humans also decided to stake their claim on
this new world for themselves, and surprised
the elves with their savagery.
As a bit of lore text from the games recounts,
A second Conjunction briefly happens in "The
Witcher 3: The Wild Hunt."
It once again brings new creatures into the
world, and even causes the elves to leave
the Continent in search of a new realm to
call home.
Because the Conjunction of the Spheres is
such a pivotal event in the history of the
Continent, Netflix is diving into that era
with a spin-off series called "The Witcher: Blood Origin."
It's set right before the Conjunction of the
Spheres and will look at how the elven empire
collapses after the disaster takes place.
"Blood Origin" will also reveal how the Conjunction
happened in the first place, and it'll even
explain how the first Witcher was created.
So, it's going to be a must-watch for fans
who want to learn more about the Continent.
"Iron Fist" writer Declan de Barra is the
showrunner on "Blood Origin," and "The Witcher"
showrunner Lauren S. Hissrich is also an executive
producer on the series.
This means it'll all fit nicely together in
the timeline, and it should hopefully answer
some key questions that fans have about the
universe.
Hissrich told Entertainment Weekly,
Netflix has amassed an impressive cast for
"Blood Origin," including "Crouching Tiger,
Hidden Dragon" and "Everything Everywhere
All at Once" star Michelle Yeoh in a lead role.
Luckily there isn't long to wait, since "Blood
Origin" arrives on Christmas Day, 2022.